- So welcome everyone.
Thank you for joining us
at the "Southeast Asia
Council Brown Bag Series"
for today's panel discussion
on Resistance and Literature
Struggles for Freedom and
Justice in Burma Myanmar.
Today's panel will include three speakers,
Thawda Aye Lei, who has
published four novels
and two short story collections.
She is currently working as a researcher
on gender and media related studies
for Burma based international NGOs.
In 2021 she enrolled in the PhD
program in political science
at McMaster University Canada.
Welcome Thawda Aye Lei.
Ko Ko Thett is a Burma born
poet, literary translator
and poetry editor for "Mekong Review."
He started writing poems
for samizdat pamphlet
at Yangon Institute of
Technology in the 1990s.
After a brush with the authorities
in 1996, student protest,
he left Burma in 1997
and has led an itinerant life ever since.
Ko Ko Thett has published and edited
several collections of poetry
and translations in both
Burmese and English.
His most recent poetry
collection is "Bamboophobia,"
from Zephyr Press.
He lives in Norwich of the UK.
Dr. Ma Thida, is currently a
visiting research associate
at the Council on Southeast
Asian Studies here at Yale,
and she's also this spearhead
organizer of this panel.
She's published more than 25 books,
including a prison memoir.
She is also an alumni of writing programs
of the University of
Iowa, Brown University,
and of Radcliffe Fellowship
at Harvard university.
She is recently elected as the chair
of the Writer in Prison
Committee of Penn International.
Please join me in welcoming
all three of these panelists.
So what we'll follow from this
point on for a little bit,
we'll open a kind of open discussion
about the literary life
of writers in Myanmar.
And what I'll do is pose a few questions
that each of the panelists
will kind of go through in a series
to talk and reflect on
some of their experiences,
and then we'll share a piece
of writing from each of them,
and then we'll have an
open Q&A after that.
So the first question I wanna ask
for all three of you
is really just to take us
into the literary world of Myanmar,
when you discovered yourself as a writer.
How did you become a writer?
And what were your influences
when you were a writer?
As a young reader,
thinking about the literary world,
who were you reading,
who you thinking about,
and what kind of conditions
were you facing as a writer?
So I'll start with Ma Thida.
- Thank you, thank you everybody,
thank you, Eric.
I think I became a very, very
voracious reader at first.
So reading makes me pretty much inspiring.
And then after that,
I think I also want to share
some of my thoughts, opinions,
and my writing skills with the readers,
then I became a writer.
That's what I'm thinking,
because reading, it's
like a new world to me,
as a teenager,
so I have been reading a lot in these days
because of these very heavy censorship.
The most available foreign
literature is Soviet literature.
So I have been pretty much like
that kind of the literature
it's already having more
on the war and peace.
- Ma Thida, you became
muted, unfortunately.
- Oh, sorry.
- You said war and peace
and then you got muted.
- Oh, sorry.
Yeah, more like in that sense,
war peace or revolution,
independence, fighting,
something like that.
So I pretty much follow
this kind of the writing
and the literature,
more on the personal autobiography
of the independence fighters,
not just from my country,
but also from all over the
world, something like that.
And then I also pretty much reading
most of the all writings too,
because there is all most
only available literature
I can get access to,
even with that it's
pretty much hard for us.
So I interested in also
with my own experience.
Both of my parents were not
from Yangon where we live,
they were from the other states
where the other ethnic minorities are.
And both of my parents are
not the Myanmar majority,
they are not the Myanmar.
So I have more experience
in Shan State and Mon State.
And every summer we visited,
especially to Mon State,
but sometimes to Shan State.
So I think because of my parents,
our families has been
traveling inside the country,
and I notice the general public,
everything is not very the same,
and the lives in the
other parts of the country
is very different from where we do live.
With that notion, I'm interested in
explaining or telling about their stories,
but at the same time,
I fall in love with the...
What should I say?
The language itself.
The grammar structure, the vocabularies,
manipulation of the vocabularies.
And the nature of the
Burmese language itself
has very rich in ambiguous vocabulary.
So many aspect of the linguists
make me wonder in writing
that kind of thing.
So I think for me, it's pretty
much mixed in that sense,
becoming a writer,
trying to talk about what's
going on on the ground
and noticing the resistance
and independence fighting of the past.
At the same time,
I have big notion
about the newest aspect
of the literature too.
But with that one,
I really wrote a lot during
my medical school days,
but I have experience, I might say,
to publish one of my short stories,
it took me 12 years.
To publish a novel, it took me 10 years,
and to publish book, it took me 30 years.
So for me, writing is not
directly related to publishing.
So without expecting much on
having chance to get published,
I keep writing.
That might be my decision throughout.
I just want to write
and I wrote that's all.
So the experience as a writer
Myanmar in this day was-
- You became muted again.
- I didn't do anything.
Maybe it's a system make me.
Sorry about that, yeah.
- Well, we'll use this as an opportunity
to turn to Ko Ko Thett.
I hope that the muting
is not a function of the
censorship you've experienced
in Myanmar sometime.
Ko Ko Thett, please tell
us about your experience
entering to the world as a writer.
- Well, I have had somewhat,
slightly different
experience than Ma Thida,
because, well, I was a key writer
during my formative year,
but I didn't know what
I would like to write,
but it was only at the campus
of Yangon Institute of Technology,
which was and remains
hub for student activism.
I became a serious poet, a samizdat poet.
We had a cycle of students
who liked to publish our own poems,
not necessarily political poems,
but we would like to
publish our own poems,
in our own way,
without having to negotiate
the repressive censorship,
that was prevalent in the
early 1990s in Myanmar.
So Ma Thida says it took years
for her to get published,
but it was very easy for us,
because it was self-published.
And the pamphlets, they
are not even books,
they are not even checkbooks,
they are really small pamphlets.
So that's how I became really into poetry.
And I think that was my first
experience of publishing.
Yeah, kind of self-published
poet to begin with.
- Ko Ko Thett, might I ask you,
this is very interesting to hear about
the way in which you started writing.
What drove you to choose poetry
as your preferred medium?
What was it that attracted you to poetry?
Was there something going on
in the exchange of other
writers in the samizdat world
or something else that inspired you
through poetry in particular?
- Yes, I was exposed to
this samizdat circle.
Most of them write poems.
And also, of course,
if you would like to publish as samizdat,
I mean, no other literary
form will be practical,
because the book has to be really slim
and will be, well, the pamphlet size,
we have to be slim and we have to be able
to be hidden into another book.
So poetry was a practical choice.
And also of course, I loved poetry
and I was inspired by
contemporary poets of Myanmar,
like Khin Zaw Myint, Aung Phyo Way
and Maung Pyiyt Min,
who I translated all over
the first 10, 20 years, yeah.
- Just wanted to ask one
more question on this
and we'll move on a little,
but could you describe the conditions
of samizdat publishing in term...
You mentioned the size of the
pamphlet needing to be slim.
I imagine that acquiring paper
and finding means to print,
were not as straightforward
as they might be
say in contemporary New
Haven where I am right now.
What were some of the
challenges that you faced
to actually produce
some of these pamphlets?
- Yes, we had had several challenges,
but my times were a little easier,
because I have seen some
earlier samizdat publications
with which were printed over
Gestetner kind of press,
which is through hand ruled,
and sometimes typed and hand ruled
and hand copied and distributed.
But in my time there were some computers,
because we were engineering students,
and one of my friends
actually ran a publication,
was a publisher.
So he helped us actually
make those pamphlets
by typing into the computer
and just printing them out.
So it was much easier for us.
But earlier than our days,
it was much more difficult.
- Let's turn now to Thawda Aye Lei.
Tell us a little bit about your experience
emerging as a writer.
- Thank you for giving me a chance
to share my passion story.
Actually, I will say it
is because of my mother
I became a writer,
because she cultivated my
reading and writing practice
since my childhood.
Because when I was a child
and it was around 10 years old,
my mother give me a book,
which is called "Zlata's Diary."
Zlata is young girl living in Sarajevo,
and she wrote about her
life during the Bosnian war
from a childs perspective.
So it's like the "Ann Frank Diary."
So she became well known
after her book released,
and finally the UN helped
her family to move to Paris.
So after reading her diary,
my mom told me if you want
to go to Paris like Zlata,
you also need to keep a diary.
So I started noting down all
my daily life into my diary.
And another thing is,
as my father is also a short story writer,
he encouraged me to work as
a journalist for a newspaper.
So after I was graduated
from the University of Foreign Languages,
I became a journalist.
So the most challenging thing at the time
it is that we didn't have
press freedom at the time.
So yeah, censorship is the
most challenging thing.
So back after 2008,
we came to know that we can
create blog and website,
and we can also post there for
anything where we wanted to.
So around 2010,
I published an online magazine,
which is called "Myat shu."
And then in 2017, yes,
I published my first novel,
which is a print version.
So to say frankly,
whenever I write something,
I feel that I am representing the group.
So that's why writing is
one of my favorite things,
because I feel that I
can represent the groups.
And then, I prefer to read the books
written by female authors, Virginia Woolf,
Simone de Beauvoir
and some other published female writers,
as I love to know how
women approach the society
from the female perspective
to literature, that's why.
Yeah, thank you.
- It's really interesting
what you were saying
about the moments in which
you were able to find the opportunity
to start publishing.
You mentioned 2010, 2017.
Many of us here recognize the importance
of that period of change.
So I'm gonna circle back to you,
'cause this is a topic I wanted to raise
with Ko Ko Thett first,
but then we'll come back to you.
I want you to pick up on that.
But the question I have.
Among scholars and observers,
2011 is often spoken of as
a kind of watershed year
as an emergence of a kind of
new set of potential freedoms.
But there's also been
talk in the scholarship
and among observers that it was a kind of
ephemeral moment as well
in the coup of 2021,
has been a very dark shift
back to an alternative,
more repressive approach to governance.
And so what I wanted you to reflect upon
is if you could tell me a little bit about
the difference as a writer,
what did it feel like to
be a writer before 2011,
from 2011 to 2021, and then today?
And to kind of give us a sense
of the really dramatic
differences of those conditions,
and what it meant to be a
writer during those periods?
And Ko Ko Thett, I
wanted to start with you,
'cause I know that you've been
an itinerant writer in many ways,
but there was a period in there
where you had returned to Myanmar as well.
And I thought you might
be able to start us off
on that conversation.
- Yes, before the decade of 2010s,
the situation when I
was living in Myanmar,
before I left Myanmar in the 1990s,
the situation was abysmal.
The decade started off with
the 1988 nationwide uprising
and then 1990 election,
where the opposition party
National League for Democracy
won a landslide.
So in that decade, dozens
of well known writers,
including Ma Thida, Ma Thanegi,
and so many others were jailed.
So the situation was really abysmal.
And to write freely means
to publish just illegally,
which we did.
So that was the situation before 2010.
And in the 2010s,
I was observing the
situation from a distance,
but three things happened I'm Myanmar.
The first thing was
introduction of the internet
or social media and mobile devices.
And the second thing was the removal
of much of the censorship in 2012.
And the third one was coming of age
of the so-called digital generation.
So these three things converged,
and there was a sea
change in the landscape,
literally landscape in Burma.
So when I returned to Myanmar in 2012,
after I left the country in 1997...
And 15 years, it took me 15
years to return to Burma.
And when I returned to
the country in 2012,
I noticed there was a sea change
in publication and literary landscape,
as if the 1990s never existed.
Having said that,
of course, some writers
and poet were also jailed
in the 2010s, and even
under the NLD government.
So today, since the February coup,
writers and poet continued to write,
but as far as I know,
no single writer or poet has been jailed
or targeted for their writing.
Writers and poets have
been jailed or murdered
because they were leading the protests
or they were part of the protests,
but not a single writer had
been jailed for their writing.
So in my opinion, it's more
like self censorship today
than the repressive regime of censorship.
- So Thawda Aye Lei,
maybe you could return to
what you were describing
about some of the transformation
in your own writing.
So how did you experience those periods?
- Yes, I would say after 2012,
we enjoyed the right to
freedom of expressions.
It's not a totally one,
because I would say
just a partial freedom,
because the government,
still wanted to push a
self censorship practice.
It means that we did not
need to submit our writings
to do their press as screening
board before publication,
but we just needed to edit
our writings by ourself.
That was not to be
against the existing law.
But you know, it's not clear
what kinds of things are supposed to be
in violation of existing laws?
That's why our life is
really risky, I will say.
So it was like we could be
taken action at any time
or prosecuted, or arrested,
under the National
Security Law, Cyber law,
or Telecommunication Law.
But I would say as long as the dictators
repression strategies are getting harsh,
our defensive mechanism
has also been changed
to respond to their repressions.
What I would like to say
is those restrictions
cannot stop our creation
and our flowing ideas.
In the previous time,
I mean initiating of
press executed involved,
the writers didn't have a chance
to talk about human rights abuse issues,
or poverty or ethnic
conflicts or democracy
through their writings,
so they had to use some metaphors.
That metaphor can reflect
what they wanted to say in some ways,
when they wanted to present a stories.
So because at the time we had
only a print media platform
that now the situation is changing
as we have online platform as well.
So the way all their
repressions were changed
to digital repressions,
along with the digital
authoritarian regime,
then our resistance
strategies were also changed.
So for the time being,
the military restricted internet line,
banned some website and
arrested some people
for using the VPN.
Although we had such kind
of challenges on our site,
we published the online newsletter,
which are more concerned
with the news article
or other creative writings,
about the current revolutions.
And we did fundraising by
using the clip to donate sites.
it means that when we visit our website
and when we have a great
number of visitor and viewers
who view the advertising on our channels,
we will earn some money.
So we post our stories or
audio books on our channels,
then we invite people to
come and visit to our site,
and read the story or
listen to the audiobooks.
By doing that, we have two benefits.
The first one is we can separate
what we want to say to the
audience through our platform.
And the second one is
we can make some income.
So that income is now going into donations
for those who joined these
civil disobedient movement
and for the IDPs,
and also for the human rights
defenders and protesters.
So that is how we resist the
repression of the military
on freedom of expression
by using the digital media.
- Thawda Aye Lei, so what
you're describing now,
these channels in which people can read
and submit a donation
for the privilege of reading the work,
those are ongoing at the
moment right now in the moment?
- Yeah.
- I wonder if maybe,
when I'm talking to Ma Thida in a moment,
if you could share a
link to some of those,
I think that would be lovely
for our viewers to know about.
- Oh, okay.
- Are there any that are
in English language also?
Not that it has to be.
- No, actually the audio
books are just in Burmese.
But yeah, I would share the link,
if you are interested in-
- Thank you, that would be wonderful.
So Ma Thida, I end with you on this topic.
How did you experience the difference
between before, during and
after the 2010s period?
- First of all,
I just want to say a couple of writer
has been arrested on the day of the coup.
So even though we cannot
say the reasons behind,
is thought to be because
of their literary works
and literally related
activities, they were arrested,
because it's was on the very
early morning of the coup,
that's why.
There are no more arrests
or killing of the writers
or poets after the coup
based on their works.
But on the day of the coup,
we really don't know why,
but they are a couple
writers like Maung Thar Cho,
Htin Lin Oo, et cetera,
So that's thought to their work
somehow related to the arrest.
So I think before 2012,
before the censorship has been released,
people struggle,
but we need to be very careful
about the period of the
censorship it's five decades.
It's from 1962 to 2012.
So for example, like some topics,
land confiscation, or
criticisms against military,
it's turned out be a taboo
topics for every people,
not just to the writers.
For that reason, I think
the self censorship
it's not being noticed as self censorship,
it's like a very standard normal practice.
The writers, the poets
might write about something,
they might be criticize,
they might be pointing out the bribery
or corruption, et cetera,
but they never ever think
so much harsh criticisms
against the military,
because it's like for them,
it is the normal standard,
not go beyond this line.
So of course it's a kind of
the unnoticed self censorship,
but at the same time,
kind of the peer censorship
is more on the racial or
religious sensitivity.
So it's, the writers tend not to write
something racially or
religiously sensitive topics,
because there will be no
censorship from the state,
but from the peer groups.
So they might get so much pressure,
that's why not many writers
are willing to cross this
line too, something like that.
So I think after the 2012
relaxation of the censorship
ending the press scrutiny board,
we do have much more chance
to be independent, to be free,
but it's also depending on
the either peer censorship
or the self censorship,
plus there are still
so many laws existing,
pretty much prohibiting
the freedom expression.
That's we have been working on.
But good thing is after 2012,
because of the Freedom of Association Law,
Freedom Association Act,
there are so many new organizations,
new institution has been game up,
for example, like PEN Myanmar.
So PEN Myanmar set up in 2013,
and then we have been
working mainly focused
on the freedom expression,
not on the literature.
But we did have a survey in 2018,
and it's for a decade from 2008 to 2018.
We have been reading more
than 3000 short stories
published in three well
known literary magazines
to find how much the Myanmar
literature is inclusive
in terms of gender, inclusive ethnicity,
in terms of the demography,
something like that.
And also we have been surveying about
what's the difference
between the topics choosing
for these stories.
What we founded out is in terms of topics,
it's not much change
before the censorship
and after the censorship,
that's mean a couple of new topics
are becoming more presentable
at the literary magazines,
for example, like love stories
of the LGBTQ community,
something like that.
And a lot of the topics like
bribery and corruption in the past,
but not many finding writing
about the land confiscation by army
or the other sufferings
in the ethnic groups.
That's, I think the
education system itself
it's pretty much the
official language is Burmese,
so that's why the language plays a role,
that's why not many ethnic
minority becoming the writers.
If they become the writers,
they cannot use their own mother tongue.
Only the Burmese language
is the medium for us.
So that's why I think
when we talk about this,
it's like not very positive
in terms of freedom
after the censorship has terminated
during the NLD government.
But I have been watching
some movie clips in the past
before the 2020 general election.
And that movie clips
is the kind of the documentary
interviewing general public
in so many different
cities inside the country.
And a lot of general
public, both men and women,
laymen, and the intellectuals,
they mentioned that during
the last five years,
they feel pretty safer to criticize
their own elected MPS,
and the regional
governments cabinet members,
something like that.
So maybe the incidence of
the number of people arrested
because it spreads freely,
it's a little bit higher
during the last five years
compared to the U then San government,
but we don't really have that
kind of the detail survey,
but it's thought to be,
more people dare enough
to practice their freedom expressions
compared to the then San's government.
That's also, we need to recognize.
So that's why I think the whole picture
is pretty much complicated.
I cannot say black and
white in that sense.
So I think a good thing is
there are a couple of the writers based
or literature based
organizations like PEN Myanmar,
is more focused on freedom expression,
but the other organization focused mainly
on writers and poets.
There are so many came up before the coup.
- Thank you so much for sharing this.
At this moment, before we turn to open up
a more open discussion,
I want to invite each of you
to share piece of your writing
with the group.
A lot of us are really eager
to hear some of your work.
So I've asked you to
choose a short passage
just to give us a taste.
And if you can just
tell us where it's from,
why you chose the piece?
And then just read it to us.
I think we we'll start with Ko Ko Thett,
then we'll turn to Thawda Aye Lei,
and then Ma Thida at the end.
And then I'll ask all of
you to reflect a little bit
on each other's writing for a moment,
and then we will open it
up to a group discussion
with the audience as well,
for question and answer.
So Ko Ko Thett, if you could
start, that'd be wonderful.
- Thank you, Erik.
I would like to read
a poem from this
collection "Bamboophobia."
And this collection was
written before 2021, actually,
and was supposed to be
published before that,
but then there was some
delay and it's just out.
So I'm going to read a
poem called "Celebrations,"
and from this "Bamboophobia."
Celebrations,
over here, we celebrate
absolutely everything,
every single day.
Every day is someone's
birthday or funeral.
Every other day is an anniversary
of a massacre or wedding,
we celebrate every week
when delouse ourselves
by rubbing our shaven heads with lime.
Every three months we deworm
our stomachs with papaya seeds.
We celebrate the spiritual
power of our polluted rivers.
We celebrate plastic in our air.
We celebrate the lives of
spiders by frying them for food.
We celebrate snakes by
skinning them into jerky.
Sex real or imagined
is the celebration of our bodies arousal.
Orgasm is a celebration of
bodies contented closure.
We celebrate celibacy.
We celebrate and are humbled
when rapist apologize.
We feast with plenty of arak
when a mother manages to rent a womb
or sell her child.
On the occasions of the funerals of poets
who died from excessive drinking,
we toast rice wine over their
graves and get this drunk.
When there is nothing to celebrate,
we celebrate for nothing with nothing.
All day long, every
single day of the year,
we smile and say to each other
(speaking in foreign language)
how are you today?
Have you eaten?
And (speaking in foreign language)
sleep well before bed.
Come morning we say,
(speaking in foreign language)
have you eaten,
to celebrate the day,
for we are still here.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Ko Ko Thett.
Thawda Aye Lei,
would you like to share a passage with us?
- Yes, I would like to share some pieces
from my short story
"The Heat of Laughter,"
because for me, I am
personally more interested
in telling the way survival of people
among the chaos conditions,
because I would like to empower
and increase their resiliency,
while are resisting the repressions.
So that's why in my short story,
"In The Heat of Laughter,"
I wrote about the sense of
humor of Burmese people,
even in the worst situation,
because it is easy to make as a set
or obsess as our world
is full of chaos things.
However, it is not easy to make a smile.
So if we can overcome such bitterness
and can make an irony towards those chaos,
I will say, is a kind of something
that we are free from all anxieties.
And I feel that the feeling of our spirit
enrich through the extreme part,
that's why I would like to highlight
the sense of humor of
Burmese people in my story.
So let me read some pieces.
The main character, Kyaw Kyaw
he is optimistic about
the current situation.
"Kyaw Kyaw was lucky.
"He was taken near the
start of the protests.
"Later, the monsters
were let loose at night.
"Criminals roamed the streets.
"Houses were set on fire.
"Curfews were imposed.
"Each day was worse than the one before,
"and all I could do was cry, curse,
"and click my tongue in bitterness.
"Kyaw Kyaw never changed though.
"After our leaders were taken,
"we marched in protest
for miles across the city.
"My belly is too fat anyway.
"It's about time I got some exercise.
"After Facebook and
other sites were blocked,
"we all turned to VPNs
and secure messaging apps.
"Before, I didn't know
anything about this technology.
"Now, I'm like an expert.
"After the state media announced
"a new raft of rules and regulations,
"we could be arrested
for any little thing.
"I'm thinking of becoming a lawyer
"with all the new laws I'm learning about.
"After the internet was cut
"between 1:00 am and 9:00 am every night,
"we went dark to the world.
"Good, now I won't stay up
so late watching videos.
"I can get back to my
normal sleep routine.
"After civilians were
chased, beaten, and shot,
"we built defense walls
across the streets.
"If this is a game, we have leveled up."
This is how Kyaw Kyaw earlier optimistic
about the current situation
with his sense of humor.
But here I forgot to mention one thing.
There is one military force shot their gun
at midnight in Yangon last year, February,
how our people respond to those gang shots
was really amazing.
At the time the military shot the gun,
as to threaten and to
make people frightened,
while they were sleeping.
That at the time we turned off the light,
and then every time we heard the gunshot,
we shouted "Happy New Year."
So our voice yelling, "Happy New Year,"
hugely covered the gunshot.
That is one of the ways we
responded to the military threat.
And I think that is truly unique,
but I forgot to include
that one in my story.
But other ways for
resistance are mentioned.
- Thank you, Aye Lei.
Ma Thida, would you
like to share a passage?
- Yes, this piece I was...
I wrote this piece after
the Saffron revolution
and I think this will
be a good one to choose.
But I couldn't read it is quite long.
So, this is the story
called "Living the Horror."
But in this piece,
I make the writer looking
for a piece of writing
and writing his O piece
and trying to edit it.
So I'm going to read
not just about the
narratives of the writer,
but about its own edited
pieces of the writing,
a bit of this, and then
the end of the story.
So here it is.
"Bang, Bang two gunshots.
"This is not a Hollywood studio,
"It is just a main
avenue in a Burmese city.
"A road peacefully used by public servant,
"civilians, students, teachers,
"street vendors, monks and nuns.
"A road throbbing with noise cars,
"chatting, blaring, music,
"birds, pigeons, and three ducks.
"But these two gunshots
have transformed it.
"Now you cannot see anybody on the avenue.
"Instead of steps,
"they are just scattered
sandals left behind.
"Not even a pigeon or a dog can be heard,
"let alone people's voices.
"It's just a far noon, but
the sky is gray and dirty,
"already threatening rain.
"The sense of food and fruits
from the street vendors
"have vanished, replaced by
smells of smoke and bullets.
"Avoiding smokey corners
the steps are wavering,
"and ash to glaze backward
is slowing down progress.
"While looking backward,
"the forward moving body is
afraid it might get pierced
"by something at the front.
"That thought hastens
the steps once again."
And another piece.
"That voice is similar.
"Yes, I heard that very
wise, not along ago,
"but then I felt safe.
"Now I feel the opposite.
"Still right now,
"I will make myself face anything,
"if it means getting a story.
"So tell me what sort of story you have.
"My voice sounds dry,
"but the relief of finding,
"I am able to master audible speech,
"steadies my trembling body.
"I am...
"But then that familiar voice
"simply fades away from my ears.
"That self formed body drift
back into the darkness,
"along with his horrid laughing face.
"The big hole on his chest,
"floats away like a flying saucer,
"moving into darkness.
"Strongly through the smell of blood
"remains as strong as ever.
"At this moment another
wave of white smoke
"rises up like a tide.
"It does not occur to me to ask
"why an avenue in the middle of this city
"has become a channel for smoke waves
"My whole attention is
focused on trying to discern
"what it is that I can see
"moving towards me in the smoke.
"What shapes are gradually emerging."
So I'm going to read the last passage.
"The images that are
deep inside the nozzle
"are gradually approaching my chest.
"I can see them now.
"I even know what they are,
"but I don't have the capacity
to define them, not yet.
"I embrace the fear.
"I try to embrace the horror,
"even the kind of horror
"that is so popular with the masses.
"But ultimately, I don't have the courage
"to express that kind of horror.
"The images are still
approaching towards my chest.
"'Stop, please stop,'
"I scream in silence and shut my eyes.
"Enough, I have no longer wish
"to continue writing this story.
"Please respect the courage
it took to make this request
"and let me leave the horror."
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
What I'd like to do,
is ask the three of you
to just reflect on each
other's passages for a moment,
and then we will open it up
to an open question and
answer with the group here.
I just, I'm curious to understand
how you receive each other's writings
and some of the thoughts that emerge
as you hear each other's work.
Maybe I'll start with Ko Ko Thett
with some reflections on the other two.
- Yes.
Thawda Aye Lei, I like
her writing and essays.
One of our essays,
"Whose Footfall is Loudest,"
is about the importance
of footwear, flip flops
in the revolution since
the 1962, 1988, 2021.
And so after a shootout,
military shootout,
people usually flee and always left,
often in the streets could be flip flops.
So she wrote about that
touchingly, poignantly.
And she is very good at
portraying mundane subjects
and people in her stories.
So my question is quite simple.
What were you reading recently,
and what was your favorite
book in Burmese or English,
fiction on nonfiction?
- Yeah, actually there
are many books I like,
so it is difficult to mention only one.
But recently, there are
some book I have read,
about those big books,
and I don't wanna share
here is a little bit boring.
So one of the book I have
recently read is, "Educated,"
which is written by Tara Westover.
Actually is like a memoir.
She wrote about herself and her family,
how she survived under
her discipline father,
he was too religious,
and how she escaped from
the stress of her brothers
who has a very abusive nature.
And even though her family
support her education,
she tell her story how she
trying to excel to education
and how she struggled to obtain PhD.
However, I think the
book is more than that,
because I feel that not
only about the education,
she really revealing about her way,
of how she deconstructs the
religious norm and gender norms,
she was shaped out for many years.
I think this is really
important from her story.
So it's really inspires to me.
- And yeah, I have a
question for Ma Thida too.
The question is that,
you've been traveling the
length and the breadth
and the depth of Burma
since all over places,
all over the places in Myanmar
Burma and Myanmar, since 1989,
you were part of the NLD campaign,
and you were traveling a lot
on that campaign in 1989.
And then by 2019,
you were also heading PEN Myanmar,
and traveling all over the places.
So which city or town Myanmar
will be very friendly or
receptive to literary personnel?
And what's the difference
from 1989 to 2019?
- It's hard to say because I
have been to so many places,
and what I remember is,
according to my experience,
appreciation for writers and poets
are mainly from the middle of
the country, Burmese majority,
because the language matters.
They can read our piece very well,
there will be no language
barrier for them.
So I think I might say the Pakokku
was one of the most
interesting during the 1988,
according to my experience,
during our visit to the
upper Burma, they show up.
And then you might notice the
very beginning of the program
or the Saffron Revolution
is also from Pakokku.
And throughout the days after 2012,
literally activities
has been pretty much
very alive in Pakokku.
So maybe I might say that...
But there are so many other cities still,
I cannot just name it.
There are so many, so many other cities,
very familiar with the...
Some cities I might say
in Ayeyarwady Division like Hinthada.
Hinthada is famous for having
at least three, four
literary activities per year.
For the other cities
they might do only once,
but for Hinthada it's might
be at least four, five,
something like that.
The poets in Hinthada
are very, very strong.
So poets have their own
choice of the literary talk,
and the other group also having their own,
something like that.
That are so many cities
are going on like this.
- Thawda Aye Lei,
would you like to pose
any questions to Ma Thida
or Ko Ko Thett?
- Yeah, first of all,
I would like to appreciate Ma Thida,
first, because of her work of
"Sanchaung, Insein, Harvard."
Harvard is the first thing
that came to my mind,
when I think of literature and resistance.
Although she wrote about her experience
as a political prisoner,
after reading her book,
rather than being afraid
of being sent to prison,
I gained the bravery to go
challenged the presidency.
So book can give us some courages,
and regarding Ko Ko Thett,
I'd like to honor his contribution
that is to engage Burmese literature
with the international communities,
because the country was so isolated
under the military regime,
for almost two decades
after 1988 revolution.
But now it's happening again.
But you didn't leave us,
and arranged the book like,
"Picking Off New Shoots
Will Not Stop the Spring."
So thanks so much for that.
So my question is so
simple, for Ko Ko Thett.
So is there any challenge
you ever experienced,
while you were arranging that book,
I mean the "New Shoots
Will Not Stop the Spring?"
And for Ma Thida, I know
now you are in jail,
so may I know your recent works?
Yeah, what are you doing there like that?
- Yes, regarding curating of
"Picking Off New Shoots
Will Not Stop the Spring."
The first challenge was,
I mean, how to collect material.
And in the beginning, February, March,
my co-editor Brian Haman and myself,
we were very much assisted
by PEN Myanmar, Ma Thida
and got lots of contributions
via PEN Myanmar.
And later I had to scan the internet
to get quality writing.
And also another challenge is diversity.
I would like to include
a polyphony of voices
in the collection.
So we had to reach out
to other resource persons
who might know, this or that
ethnic writer and so on.
So that way, we were able to include
so many different voices in the book.
Another challenge is to
get it done in one year.
Because, most of the translation
was done by me, single handedly,
even though there are several other pieces
written in English.
So that was a full-time job,
almost from March to September.
So that was a challenge.
- Yes, sayar ma Ma Thida
- Thank you.
Indeed, I was about to read a small poem,
it's called, "Get Out of The Maze.
That's what I'm doing here.
I'm thinking of writing a new novel,
but in order to write that novel
I need a lot of information.
So I have been closely
watching my own country,
what's going on,
and not just currently,
but also during the last decades.
I trying to understand,
I also here at YALE,
I try to reach out to
that diaspora population,
either in person or through the internet.
I reach out to them
and I try to understand
the whole picture what's going on.
And I'm going to start my new book,
but still struggling about the structure,
because my dream is quite a little big.
And then the atrocity
doesn't stop, it's going on.
So I might decide the
period to end for my piece,
so that will be my future book.
That will be amazed.
- Thank you so much.
I wanna open up to open Q&A
from some of our
attendees in the audience.
So if you would like to ask a question,
just raise your hand,
using the hand raise function
of the Zoom interface.
If you can't find that,
just wave your hand and
I'll try and see you,
but you'll have to show
your video to do that one.
I see a question from Al Lim
- Hi everyone.
Thank you so much for the
wonderful presentation.
And it's great to see you.
I think Ko Ko Thett
visited a few years ago
and we had to have lunch
at some point there
it was wonderful.
So it's thank you again for talking about
the kind of state of Burmese poetry
and how y'all are gonna
contributing so well,
both kind of in, in Myanmar
and internationally.
I think my question is about
the state of Burmese poetry
for like young people.
I'm wondering, like, is it
a big thing in universities?
Like how do people get into it?
Can you just talk a little bit more about
the state of Burmese poetry in Myanmar,
both in Yangon and in other cities,
and just as a part of comparison,
like in Singapore,
there's a big Singapore
poetry writing month
that Joshua Ip, and a few folks run.
And it's being taught in schools,
so that's one way people get into it.
Whereas in Thailand,
it's not as big for like
young people, I feel,
where it's a lot more kind of like formal
and very strict and rigid.
And so I'm just wondering,
how did you know people get into it?
It's great to hear from you.
I'm just curious about how
vibrant it is as a community.
Thank you.
- Yes, I can speak of poetry
as a curriculum in school,
which is actually hopeless,
because Burmese school curriculum,
they hardly teach any free thinking.
So most of the poems are quite rigid,
and they don't teach
contemporary poetry at all.
Most of the poets are
dead and in long gone.
So that's one thing.
Maybe that's the reason
why on the other hand,
there's a vibrant,
unofficial learning of poetry
and other modes of literature in Burma.
So I often speak of this
participatory poetry
written by ordinary people
who are not necessarily poets,
because our Burmese language
also is quite the rhyming language.
And if you are observing
the protests even in 2021,
most of the protest
slogans were in couplets
written by participatory poets.
Very powerful and very in
your face, against the regime.
So these are very
impressive lines, such as
(speaking in foreign language)
No negotiation for blood debt.
And even "Picking Off New Shoots
Will Not Stop the Spring,"
that come from the protests of Burma.
So anyway, that's one thing.
And on the other hand,
there are career poets
and professional poets.
And Ma Thida said,
in different cities and towns,
there are centers for...
How shall I say it?
There are literary groups, poetry groups,
who usually gather at
tea shops, coffee shops,
and they just discuss their poems.
And just like workshops in the West,
but they do usually
workshop each other poems,
but still that's in different cities,
there're different centers of poetry.
Like Monywa has a very
vibrant center of poetry.
And we lost two Monywa
poets in 2021 uprising.
- Thank you Ko Ko Thett.
Paul Sarno, you can ask a question.
- This is directed to Ma Thida.
I read and found very informative
your book called "Prisoner of Conscience."
And I understand you've written
a second book in English.
I can't seem to find it
on the world catalog.
Can you tell me, please,
the English title and the
publisher, if you know.
- Yes, the book is called "The Roadmap,"
but it might appear
under the name of my
pseudonym, Suragamika,
the same publisher,
the Silkworm Publication
from Chiang Mai, Thailand.
But that was the earlier a book.
I wrote that book in English.
"The Roadmap," I wrote
that book in English.
At that time, because of the situation,
I dare not to use my own name,
so I used a pseudonym Suragamika,.
And then that book was written at Brown,
and I moved to Redcliff Harvard next year,
and I finished writing my
prison memoir there, in Burmese,
but that the translation was published,
as "A Prisoner Conscience."
- Thank you.
- How do you spell Sira, S-I-R-
- Sura, S-U-R-A-G-A-M-I-K-A, Suragamika.
It's kind of a Pali words,
Sura means brave, Gamika is a traveler.
- Suragamika.
- Yes.
- A with a K.
- A, K.
- K.
- Okay, thank you.
Also, if I can ask one more question?
I wondered about how many
poets, writers that you know of
have left Myanmar, since the coup?
More than 20, more than 30, how many?
- It's hard to say most of them,
for example, like five were killed,
and round about 14 were in prison,
and then a lot has been left,
but most of the writers and poets
are resisting from the land, from inside.
They keep doing.
- Have they joined the P the...
Oh, I'm sorry,
I can't remember the abbreviation,
but the forces that are
the fighting the junta.
- PDF?
- Yeah, I'm sorry.
The PDF of the NG.
Have they joined them?
- Yes, some already joined.
Yeah, some already joined the PDF.
And, you know, the minister
of the Ministry of Defense
of NUG, himself is a poet.
- Ah, okay.
Thank you so much.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Thank you.
- Do we have any other questions?
I have one, but I don't wanna
keep asking the only question.
I wanna open it up to others.
Eric White, we have question.
- Hi, thanks.
So, in general, there's
been a lot of discussion
about since the coup,
there's been greater engagement,
reproachment and solidarity
between the ethnic Burman
majority populations
and the ethnic minority populations.
And I'm just wondering,
do we see similar dynamics
within the community of
writers of poetry and prose
in the sense of as communities of writers,
as communities of readers,
as community of commentators?
So just wondering how
of the coup has changed
the character actually,
of communities of writers and readers
inside of Myanmar and across
ethnic kinds of boundaries?
- I think, I answer your question.
It's hard.
That's why PEN Myanmar has a plan
to have a short story writing Workshop
with minorities,
especially we pick Kayah, Mon,
Chin and Kachin and Shan.
So that's the program.
According to our survey in 2018,
there is almost very few
from the ethnic minority
becoming a well known writer.
Even though we do have a couple
of the active communication
between these ethnic
minorities, it's very hard.
That's why I think the ethnic literature
is almost not existing.
For example, like in Kachin language,
there is only the translation of the Bible
into Kachin language.
There is not much other literature,
even though they do have kind of video
or the feature movie, something like that,
but not in literature form.
So it's very hard only
in Shan and Mon language
have their own literature,
but it's not very popular,
it's never been translated into Burmese
to reach out to the broader audience.
So it's very hard to make a communication
between the writers
written in Burmese language
with the writers, written in
other different languages.
Only we PEN Myanmar try to reach out,
but it's not yet successful,
because of the coup.
We had planned to have a short
story training in Shan State
on 22nd February,
and it was banned.
I think Jane wants to add something.
She's a part in Shan, even
though I'm Shan, I don't.
- Go ahead, Jane.
And while you're talking,
I'm going to announce
your talk next week too.
I'll put it in the chat, so people.
- Yeah, thank you for...
Oh, am I frozen now?
- Oh, just for a second.
Unfrozen now.
- Yeah, there is the thing, chilled.
So the longest continuously operating
Shan printing press in Taunggyi,
has a huge Pantheon of Shan poetry,
Shan short stories, comic books,
that have been continuously operating,
but then also in the Shan
liberated territories
from the seventies, eighties,
and nineties onwards,
they operated a lead Linotype
type setting machines.
So the constant production,
and with the digital age,
there's a whole lot out there.
But also specifically
because this revolutionary,
the ongoing civil war
and the ongoing resistance in Shan State
is in some ways separate
from the activities
that have been going on against the coup
in the Burmese Heartland.
So there's a political
different orientation,
just to summarize it very, very simply.
But especially about Shan
revolutionary singers,
some of them will make
Burmese versions of the songs.
So if we want to broaden poetry
to include rock and roll and songs,
there's a tremendous amount of crossover
between Shan artists
and making songs that are accessible
to Burma people who don't know Shan.
So the language and
the political division,
can be transgressed in really fascinating
and revolutionary ways.
- Go ahead Thawda.
- Yeah, I would like to add something.
Even though we are not engaging
our ethnic or communities in the coup.
Before the coup, as much as I remembered,
we had a poetry event two years ago.
In that poetry event, we
brought the Rohingya poets,
to recite the poems.
To reveal the experience.
And then even in the new book of
"Picking Off New Shoots,"
I think some of the writers,
even though they are
not the ethnic people,
I mean they're just Burma.
I think some of their writers
can cover other ethnic experience.
Like the poem of Cathy.
I think Ko Ko Thett can
also share that poem,
(speaking foreign language)
Was written by Cathy.
His poem is really amazing,
and I think there is really engaging
with the other minorities
experience and sufferings.
(speaking foreign language)
- By Cathy is not in the
collection anthology,
"Picking of New Shoots
Will Not Stop the Spring,"
but a translation of
that poem is published
in the research,
the channel of Burma research
that's out, I think last week.
So there's that poem there,
but in "Picking Off New Shoots
Will Not Stop the Spring,"
anthology itself,
there are three Rohingya
poets from different places,
Cox's Bazaar, Malaysia
refugee camp and Canada.
So we are quite happy and honored
that they are contributing
those poems to this anthology.
- So I wanted to ask a
question for all three of you
about the relationship
between content and form
in periods of resistance.
And the question that has
long been on my mind...
Actually before the events in Myanmar
with my work in Vietnam,
one of the burdens that some of my friends
who are Vietnamese artists
often described to me,
is how as artists, they
want to be experimental
in particularly artistic ways
that are not always
driven by telling a story
about Vietnam for example.
Their artistic expression
transcends Vietnam nest,
or something like,
or Vietnamese nest,
or telling the story of "the Vietnam war"
or something of that.
And I've always been curious,
even with the title of this panel
of Resistance and Literature,
what it's like to be a writer
who wants to play with language
for the sake of language?
Ko Ko Thett, you mentioned
some of the couplet forms
or some of the literary
styles of Burmese language.
Ma Thida mentioned,
when she was younger,
when she first got excited
about being a writer
as just the beauty of the language itself.
Sometimes that's political,
and sometimes it's not.
Sometimes it's just artistic expression.
But Ko Ko Thett you also mentioned
how they're the rigid form
of certain forms of poetry,
has also linked to a kind of
repressive educational system too.
And so I wondered if the
three of you could reflect
just a little bit about
artistic expression
and the burden of representing resistance,
and how you manage that a little bit
and how you engage with that.
- Yes, I meant to say
that the rigid form itself
is not to blame.
I mean, when you write in the rigid form,
it can lead to uncertain turn.
But, what I meant is that
the curriculum itself
that makes the rigid form.
And then of course the curriculum itself
is full of poems, that nationalist
kind of poems and so on,
this makes it very problematic
to become a creative writer.
But when it comes to
writing and resistance,
I like to quote the Peruvian
novelist, Mario Vargas Llosa.
He said that, "The mere
existence of literature
"is a subversive act."
For instance, Burmese novelist Sei Sei
in the 1950s,
wrote her memoirs about
the stigma of syphilis.
That was in the 1950s.
And the book in my opinion,
was a subversive act,
in a time syphilis was
looked down as a curse
or one's bad karma.
So we can actually write
about personal experience
as personal stigma,
and becomes subversive in our
own culture in our own way.
So for me, the only responsibility
for writers is to write,
and beyond that they
should not feel any burden
or any expeditions from anyone,
because I think resistance writing,
just like all other creative activities
must come from within
oneself, not from the outside.
So a piece of writing...
In my opinion, a piece of writing
that responds to a groups
or an individual's political expectations
is rhetoric or propaganda.
- I think, yeah, I also.
I published a book it's
called "My Writing."
Because it has been
pretty much contradictory
to have so many people saying,
"Oh, your piece of writing is a poetry,
"or an essay, or a short story.
"We don't know what it is."
And I said, "Okay, I also
don't know what it is,
"because I'm not an academy.
"I just create it.
So let's call my writing, that's all.
(speaking foreign language)
And that one,
it's pretty much like
focusing on the strength
of the language itself.
It might reflect some political issue,
because I think as a writer,
we just use our own
individual way of response
to the universe.
So if the universe surrounding
us is pretty much political,
our response will be
more or less political.
There is no way to escape from it.
That's all.
We just reflecting whatever
we are surrounded by,
something like that.
So even though as an individual writer,
of course our strength,
it's also not just our perspective
towards something else,
but also the skills,
the aesthetic, intrinsic
part of the aestheticness,
it's also our strength.
So that's directly really to how much
we can play with the language,
the linguist parts of our own languages.
That's why I think this is very much...
When we talk about the freedom expression,
we need to talk about the language rights.
So that's how I see,
and I enjoy as a writer.
We are the owner of our own
reflection towards the universe,
- Yes, for me, I would like to mention
about social resistant through literature,
rather than the resistant
to the dictatorship.
Because I think I could say
that bringing social justice
and eliminating social inequalities,
is much more difficult than
it is to end the dictatorship,
because that discriminatory
norms and values
are deeply rooted in our
society for many centuries.
That's why, when I'm
trying to write something
that is to deconstruct the norms,
I have to cautious and not to use
the old words repetitively,
because of by using this again, again,
I'm afraid of strengthening
or reinforcing that words.
That's why I try to
interchange with other words.
For example, in my second
novel "A West Minded Tomorrow,"
it is about a young woman who
caused psychological trauma
since she was young,
because of her sexual
violence of her cousin,
as well as abandoned of her father.
So in that case,
the people surrounding her said,
that she suffering from hysteria,
but she hates that word.
What I want to say in that novel
is the word hysteria is too gendered.
In this framing,
most people think it is
concerned only with women.
And I also want to
explain how Myanmar women
are afraid of being hysterical.
So that's why,
women, they keep their love expressions
and never declared their
love before men do.
And the story also tells
about how much difficult
of Myanmar women to divorce their husband.
So in that story, as I
wanted to deconstruct
the term hysteria,
I didn't use the word in the whole story.
Instead, I tried to
either change other words,
to just say that female
character suffering
is just a kind of psychological
problems like others.
It's not concerned with
female body and womb
as we used to believe in the past.
So one main problem is,
whenever I get the all
norms to deconstruct,
I have to be cautious of using the words,
If I said to you before.
So if we use the old terms,
I'm afraid that meaning
relating to those specific words
became repeated and it's like
reinforcing the meanings.
That's why I have to
be cautious about that.
- Thank you so much for
this fascinating discussion.
I noticed that we're
near the end of our time.
So I'm gonna bring the
conversation to a close.
I'm gonna turn off the recording,
but I'll leave the Zoom
open for a few minutes,
if anyone wants to have any informal chat.
For those of us who are still with us,
please join me in thanking
our wonderful panelist,
for a great conversation.
(attendees clapping)